Guten Morgen, Sabrina.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Was machen wir jetzt mit dieser Sitzung hier?
Ich würde sagen, die eröffnen wir.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 489 vom 9. April 2024. 24.
Und ja, ihr werdet es schon gemerkt haben, der Linus ist nicht da,
der ist immer noch verhindert.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, mache ich heute mal eine kleine Sonderausgabe,
nutze die Gelegenheit und lade die Sabrina ein. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Hallo, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, Sabrina, Sabrina, jeder dich kennen wahrscheinlich, manche und manche nicht. Ein paar.
Ein paar kenne ich, genau. Ein paar haben dich schon mal gehört,
weil du bist ja auch Podcasterin.
Und bist im weiteren Sinne auch im, Klammer auf, Netz, Klammer zu,
politischen Umfeld unterwegs, kann man sagen.
Ja, also eher Digitalpolitik tatsächlich.
Erzählen, wo du so hergekommen bist. Wo ich so hergekommen bin.
Also wie du vor allem ins Digitale geraten bist. Sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, ich versuche es mal irgendwie etwas über 40 Jahre ganz kurz zu fassen.
Ja, wie bin ich da hingekommen? Ich bin von Haus aus gelernter IT-Systemkauffrau.
Bin hauptberuflich auch Windows-Admin und Datenbank-Admin.
Das heißt also, ich bin sowieso mit dem Digitalen und dem Netz irgendwie beschäftigt.
Und da interessiert einen das natürlich auch.
Aber zum Podcasten,
Bin ich, glaube ich, so gekommen wie die meisten, weil irgendwann denkt sich
ja jeder, irgendwie müsste man mal einen Podcast machen.
Scheinbar. Ich kenne das Gefühl. Also irgendwie das Gefühl hat man ja schon,
dass jeder diesen Gedanken irgendwann mal hat.
Und ja, warum gerade mit dem Thema ist halt, oder ich weiß nicht,
ob wir da jetzt schon direkt reingrätschen wollen.
Können wir machen. Also der Podcast, den du machst, heißt Parlamentsrevue.
Und es ist, wie der Name schon nahelegt, eine Art Überblick über das Geschehen
im deutschen, bundesdeutschen Parlament, beziehungsweise des gesamten Gesetzesprozesses.
Ich glaube, du fokussierst dich ja auf und orientierst dich an den Sitzungen,
also den Sitzungswochen des Bundestages, richtig?
Genau. Also ich versuche eigentlich einmal im Monat dann alle Sitzungen dieses
Monats oder alle vorangegangenen Sitzungen dann irgendwie zu begleiten und versuche auch alle Gesetze,
die verabschiedet wurden und alle relevanten Anträge oder Beschlüsse zumindest
einmal kurz zu erwähnen.
Also es soll schon irgendwie so der vollständige Überblick werden,
das ist so ein bisschen mein Ziel.
Und dann höre ich halt für die interessanteren Themen, höre ich halt in die
Debatten rein, versuche da so ein bisschen die Argumente auseinanderzunehmen,
wenn ich mich irgendwie so ein bisschen damit auskenne.
Das sind ja so viele Themen, das kriegt man dann ja natürlich gar nicht alles abgedeckt,
aber wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich mich auskenne oder was vielleicht nicht
ganz so komplex ist oder so, dann zerlege ich das auch gerne mal und mache mich
auch gerne mal ein bisschen drüber lustig.
Ja, das gelingt ja auch ganz gut. Also mich würde mal interessieren,
was so eigentlich deine ursprüngliche Motivation war.
Ich habe mal was ähnliches gemacht, ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das weißt,
ich habe ja mal so ein Projekt gehabt damals mit Philipp Banse,
das war mehr so ein Experiment, Bundesradio hieß das.
Und das war tatsächlich genau die Idee, also sozusagen Bundestagsgeschehen und
Gesetzesgeschehen, das ist doch irgendwie alles interessant und das betrifft
uns doch und das ist halt auch wieder so etwas,
die meisten Leute verstehen es nicht so richtig, weil es halt auch keiner so
richtig verfolgen möchte und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir so ein bisschen gegrübelt, was da so unser Modus sein kann
und haben es dann mal probiert mit.
Ausschusssitzungen herausgreifen und dann vor Ort sein und sich da irgendwelche,
Vortragenden, also jetzt nicht von den Parteien, sondern so diesen Experten,
die dann immer geladen werden, die zu greifen und dann mal so das Thema durchzusprechen.
Hat sich alles als nicht wirklich gangbarer Weg herausgestellt,
deswegen ist das dann auch nach ein paar Sendungen auch wieder eingeschlafen, was kein Problem ist.
Philipp Banse macht Macht ja jetzt sehr erfolgreich Lage der Nation.
Ulf Burmeier hat da sozusagen das Format dann auch gefunden.
Und naja, hier war es ja, Logbuch-Netzpolitik hat auch seine eigene Art und
Weise, darauf zu schauen.
Aber du gehst ja da sehr strukturiert und sehr zielgerichtet sozusagen nach
dem Programm des Bundestages ran.
Ja genau, also da sind halt so ein bisschen zwei Gedanken zusammengekommen.
Einmal dieser Gedanke, man müsste eigentlich mal einen Podcast machen.
Und dann hatte ich schon länger so einen Gedanken, der wie mietfrei in meinem Kopf wohnte,
dass ich gedacht habe, es müsste doch eigentlich mal entweder ein Podcast oder
ein YouTube-Channel oder irgendwas, also irgendein Medium geben,
das einfach mal vollständig beleuchtet, was in diesem Bundestag passiert.
Eben nicht nur die relevanten Themen, über die halt alle reden,
sondern wirklich mal auflistet. Das ist übrigens noch passiert und dann gab es noch den Beschluss.
Und so ist jetzt, diese Dinge sind halt im Bundestag passiert.
Und das gab es einfach nicht. Und ich habe das nicht, gibt es auch anscheinend
bis heute nicht so richtig.
Also die meisten, die sich halt damit beschäftigen, es gibt ja zigtausend Podcasts
auch aus den, von den großen Zeitungen und so weiter, die irgendwie Hauptstadtberichterstattung machen,
aber auch die kümmern sich immer nur um so Einzelthemen, über die halt,
wie gesagt, alle reden. Ja.
Und diese ganzen kleinen Themen, die da noch so sind, die gehen irgendwie total unter.
Und das war so meine Motivation oder unsere Motivation damals.
Wir haben ja angefangen zu zweit.
Da war noch meine Podcast-Partnerin Corinna mit dabei.
Und diesen Gedanken hatten wir halt beide, dass wir das irgendwie mal vollständig begleiten wollten.
Und da kam uns dann die Bundestagswahl halt gelegen, wo wir dachten,
ach Mensch, jetzt hier fängt die neue Legislaturperiode an. Das ist doch eine
gute Gelegenheit, das mal anzufangen.
Am 26.10.2021, das war die erste Sitzung, die ihr beleuchtet habt und das heißt,
du machst es jetzt auch schon seit über zwei Jahren.
Genau, ich mache das jetzt seit über zwei Jahren. Corinna ist dann,
ich glaube, nach anderthalb Jahren oder so, also jetzt ungefähr vor einem Jahr,
ist sie dann halt ausgestiegen, hauptsächlich aus Zeitgründen.
Und seitdem mache ich das jetzt halt alleine. Und ja, es hat auch ein bisschen
gedauert, bis wir da erst zu zweit und dann ich alleine so unser Format gefunden haben.
Aber ich glaube, mittlerweile hat sich das einigermaßen eingependelt.
Ist ja gar nicht so einfach, alleine einen Podcast zu machen. Nee, das stimmt.
Also ich versauere da schnell und fühle mich verloren.
Ich brauche immer irgendeinen, den ich so anreden kann.
Das kann ich gut verstehen. Weil ich habe tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen das
Problem, also ich kann grundsätzlich sowieso nicht wahnsinnig gut freisprechen.
Was man nicht merkt im Übrigen. Wir haben gerade erst angefangen.
Vor allem ist es immer schwierig, wenn ich meine Witze nicht vorschreiben kann,
dann bin ich so auf mein Standardrepertoire angewiesen. Das ist auch nicht ganz einfach.
Aber tatsächlich in so einen leeren Raum reinzusprechen und nur in so ein Mikro
reinzusprechen, ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach. weil mein Gehirn irgendwie
nicht versteht, dass es Sachen wirklich ausformulieren muss, auch wenn keiner da ist.
Und ich hatte tatsächlich in den ersten Aufnahmen dann öfter mal den Fall,
dass so ein halber Satz einfach fehlte, weil mein Gehirn den einfach nur gedacht
hat und ich nicht gemerkt habe, dass ich den gar nicht wirklich ausgesprochen habe.
Das führt dann dazu, dass mittlerweile tatsächlich auch ich alles geskriptet
habe. Also ich lese im Prinzip vor, muss ich sagen.
Es ist sehr wenig, dass ich tatsächlich freispreche. Erstmal,
weil ich ja auch die Fakten richtig haben möchte.
Ich möchte nicht irgendwelche Zahlen einfach so vor mich hin erzählen, die dann nicht stimmen.
Das ist natürlich auch immer ganz wichtig.
Und eben dieser Effekt, dass ich nicht vergesse, irgendwas zu sagen,
weil ich nicht merke, dass ich es gar nicht sage.
Nachvollziehbar, naja, aber da ist ja dann mittlerweile ein ganz brauchbares
Kompendium rausgekommen und ja, also es ist, man kriegt sehr schnell ein Gefühl,
okay, worum ging es alles, du suchst ja dann sozusagen die wichtigsten Gesetzesinitiativen,
die besprochen werden, heraus. raus?
Also gibt's da irgendwie also was ist so deine Maßstab für was ist wichtig und
was ist jetzt quasi unter ferner Liefen so?
Ob's mich interessiert.
Ob's dich interessiert?
Ob's mich interessiert oder nicht.
Okay, und was interessiert dich?
Also erstmal alles, so grundsätzlich. Nein, also ja, was interessiert mich?
Ich glaube, da gibt's keinen wirklich roten Faden. Das ist auch sehr tagesformabhängig.
Also Also dieses ganze Thema Digitales und so hat natürlich irgendwie einen
gewissen Schwerpunkt, aber mich interessiert auch viel so Ernährungsgesetzgebung,
alles was so Landwirtschaft,
Tierhaltung, Tierschutz und solche Dinge interessieren mich.
Aber auch, ja, wie funktioniert unser Staat?
Also auch so absurde Dinge wie das Gesetz zum deutschen Wetterdienst oder so,
wo man sich denkt, so, ja, habe ich noch nie darüber nachgedacht.
Natürlich muss es da irgendwie ein Gesetz geben, aber wie funktioniert das eigentlich?
Also das ist so ein Motivator.
Ich finde das auch ganz gut, weil das war auch, als ich Bundesradio gemacht
habe, relativ schnell so eine Erkenntnis und auch eigentlich so ein bisschen
mein Leitmotiv ist ohnehin, alles ist interessant,
es ist immer nur die Frage, wie man drauf schaut oder wie man nachfragt.
Und was glaube ich bei der Parlamentsrevue sehr schnell rüberkommt ist,
dass man einfach merkt, okay, alles klar, die müssen sich da mit allem rumschlagen.
Ja, genau.
Bist du im Bundestag, hast du quasi mit jedem Bereich unserer Gesellschaft irgendwas zu tun?
Heute wird über Krieg geredet und morgen über Standardisierungsformate für Flansche
im industriellen Rahmen oder keine Ahnung.
Teilweise back to back. Also die haben eine Debatte zu Ukraine-Hilfen und dann
direkt danach haben sie irgendwie was zur Wahlgesetz und dann direkt danach
irgendwas zu irgendeiner Änderung
im Bundesberggesetz oder sowas und das einfach im Halbstundentakt.
Aber alles ist halt irgendwie relevant für irgendjemanden in Deutschland und
das dann eben auch zu verstehen, wie diese ganzen Prozesse funktionieren,
finde ich halt auch ganz interessant.
Was sind denn so Erkenntnisse, die dir so gekommen sind jetzt nach zwei Jahren Begleitung?
Verstehst du jetzt irgendwas,
Besser oder anders formuliert, hast du jetzt mehr Verständnis für bestimmte
Dinge, wie sie sind oder hat sich bei dir eigentlich nur das Entsetzen breit gemacht?
Ah, auch das ist tagesformabhängig.
Also man sieht natürlich, wenn man da so intensiv drauf guckt,
auf alles drauf guckt, sieht man natürlich auch viel mehr, wie so Sachen gegeneinander
aufgewogen werden oder wie da so Deals zustande kommen.
So, wir geben euch jetzt bei dem Gesetz noch das und dafür kriegen wir bei dem
Gesetz aber dieses und so.
Also diese Punkte sieht man halt, finde ich, sehr viel stärker.
Da kann man, je nachdem, wie gut man geschlafen hat, kann man dann mehr Verständnis
haben oder man kann wütender werden.
Das ist so ein bisschen eine Frage der Perspektive.
Aber diese Deals sind ja schon auch ein bisschen die Essenz des Kompromisses. Ja, das ist es.
Aber manchmal ist es halt schon so, wo man sagt, okay, das kann man doch jetzt
nicht gegeneinander aufwiegen.
Also da geht es um das Leben von Menschen irgendwie und das andere ist irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, eine Zahl auf irgendeinem Konto.
Also manchmal ist es schwierig, aber manchmal sieht man auch,
also manchmal, ich habe schon mehr Verständnis jetzt dafür,
ja, dass man eben unterschiedliche Interessen halt irgendwie unter einen Hut kriegen muss und das…,
Geht gar nicht immer argumentativ.
Dann ist es halt einfach Tippo-Tett und dann so, ja okay, hier haben wir verloren,
aber da haben wir gewonnen.
Ja genau, einmal sowas und auch halt, dass eben auch Interessen eine Rolle spielen,
die jetzt nicht die eigenen sind.
So, wo man sagt ja, wie kann man so sein?
Das stimmt ja nicht mit euch. Aber auch das ist halt ein richtiges Interesse,
das irgendwie Berücksichtigung finden muss.
Und was ist dann so in der Summe dein Eindruck von unseren Parlamentariern?
Also was überwiegt da?
Was überwiegt da? Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Man hört halt leider so wenige. Also es sind am Ende dann doch fast immer dieselben
Leute, die vorne stehen und eine Rede halten.
Und ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Also ob die nicht nach vorne gelassen werden.
Hörst du dir das alles an?
Nein, alles nicht. Das ist zeitlich nicht machbar. Also die Debatten,
die halt das große Thema sind, die höre ich mir an komplett.
Aber jetzt nicht jeder einzelne. Also alles, was unter Sonstiges landet,
die habe ich mir dann nicht angehört.
Aber schon einiges.
Aber schon einiges, ja. Und wenn ich was Besonderes wissen habe oder noch irgendeine
Frage offen habe oder so, gucke ich mir dann auch oft die Anhörung dazu noch
an und dann vielleicht auch noch irgendwie eine Pressekonferenz, die es dazu gab.
Also ich versuche dann auch schon Zitate und O-Töne aus anderen Quellen noch mit dazu zu kriegen.
Okay, also es gibt welche, die stehen sozusagen im Vordergrund.
Was ist so dein Eindruck, den du dabei gewinnst?
Es ist sehr gemischt. Also es gibt Leute, die finde ich sehr offensichtlich
einfach nur irgendwelche Partikular- und Klientelinteressen vertreten.
Es gibt aber auch viele, denen es wirklich darum geht…,
Irgendwie das Land besser zu machen und irgendwie die Lebenssituation von Leuten besser zu machen.
Das gibt's alles. Also immer dieses Pauschale, ja, die sind ja die da oben und
die sind ja alle korrupt und so, das ist halt Quatsch.
Also ein paar ja, glaube ich, das kann man, glaube ich, in Medienberichten immer
wieder nachlesen, aber viele auch, denen geht es wirklich um die Sache und denen
liegt auch die Sache sehr am Herzen.
Und das ist halt, ja, es ist halt, es ist sehr, sehr gemischt.
Auch über die Parteien gemischt. Also man kann auch nicht sagen,
die Partei, das sind alles die Guten und die Partei, das sind alles die Korrupten,
sondern das ist, in allen Parteien hast du die, die hauptsächlich,
denen es hauptsächlich um ihr persönliches Fortkommen geht und ihre Karriere,
als Berufspolitiker und du hast diejenigen in allen Parteien,
fast allen Parteien, die, denen es halt irgendwie um die Sache geht.
Ich glaube es verteilt sich aber bei den einzelnen Parteien aber auch sehr unterschiedlich.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und manche kann man halt auch ausklammern.
Ja, aber du hast ja dann auch ein bisschen Technik an den Start gebracht,
um dir sozusagen die Arbeit ein bisschen zu erleichtern.
Kannst du das mal erläutern?
Ja, so zwangsweise.
Ja, weil es ist ja viel, was nimmst du denn von so einer Sitzungswoche als erstes
wahr, wenn die aufgerufen wird?
Also ich gucke halt erstes Mal in die Tagesordnung, was da überhaupt anstand und was anlag.
Und dann picke ich mir die Themen raus und gucke vor allem in meine ausführliche Liste.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, wie ich auf die Frage antworten soll.
Naja, also worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, du hast ja so ein Tool
gebaut, diesen Bundestagszusammenfasser.
Ja.
Was macht das?
Das ist im Grunde die Fortentwicklung meiner Liste, die wir halt von Anfang
an geführt haben, um überhaupt nur den Überblick zu behalten,
was gerade wo ist, was es überhaupt für Vorhaben gibt,
auf welchem Stand die sind und was damit schon passiert ist.
Das hat angefangen ganz am Anfang mit einer Excel-Liste, natürlich.
Und das war dann sehr schnell viel zu wenig.
Und dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, ach Mensch, wenn wir das jetzt eh pflegen,
könnte ja eventuell die HörerInnen auch interessieren, kann ich ja mal online stellen.
Dann hatte ich es erst als einzelne, eigene Rubrik sozusagen auf der Webseite,
wo eben auch der Podcast ist.
Und dann wollte ich eigentlich nur eine Kleinigkeit hinzufügen und das ist dann
so ein bisschen ausgeartet.
Und jetzt ist dann halt das eine eigene Webseite geworden, der Bundestagszusammenfasser,
auf der halt die Gesetzesvorhaben, die den Bundestag betreffen,
aufgelistet sind in den verschiedenen Status.
Und wo man halt für alle Gesetze halt nachgucken kann. Erstens einmal die Basisdaten
halt, worum geht es überhaupt grob.
Die Links von der Ministeriumseite sind da verlinkt.
Und es gibt halt eine GPT-4-Zusammenfassung Einmal vom Gesetz selber,
von der Anhörung und von der Beschlussempfehlung, wenn sie denn da ist.
Also so kann man dann da genau verfolgen, wann war das Gesetz wo,
wann ist was passiert und was ist eben an den verschiedenen Stationen an Text entstanden.
Wo kommen die Daten her?
Die ziehe ich mir, also es ist kompliziert.
Sobald das Gesetz irgendwie entweder im Bundestag oder im Bundesrat angekommen
ist, ab da läuft alles wunderbar automatisch, weil ab da kann man die API abfragen,
die vom Bundestag zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Das ist dann deren Dokumentenmanagementsystem, das heißt DIP,
also D-I-P, wo ich gerade nicht weiß, wofür das steht leider.
Aber egal, ist einfach deren Dokumentenmanagementsystem, das kann man abfragen
und da kriegt man dann jeden Statuswechsel und jeden Vorgang kriegt man da mit.
Und da habe ich mir mit make.com diverse Automatismen und diverse Szenarien
gebaut, die mir das halt abfragen und die mir das in meine Datenbank schreiben.
Kann ich noch gar nicht. Heißt übrigens Dokumentations- und Informationssystem
für Parlamentsmaterialien.
Sehr sperrig.
Ja, bleiben wir bei DIP.
Genau, bleiben wir bei DIP.
Hätte es auch besseren Namen gegeben, Jorgen.
Okay, das heißt, vielleicht nochmal kurz ein Blick, also bundeszusammenfasser.de,
das ist die Domain und dort kann man dann halt auf der Homepage erstmal sehen,
so ein kurzer Teaser, was ist irgendwie neu im Bundestag, was sind Gesetze,
die hängen seit ewigen Zeiten rum.
Ich weiß nicht, was da der Threshold ist, aber so ab 150 Tagen oder so, kann das sein?
Nee, es sind einfach die ältesten fünf.
Ah, die ältesten fünf, alles klar. Also Demokratiefördergesetz ist seit 385
Tagen in der Ausschussberatung, steht hier als erstes sozusagen.
Und wird es wohl auch noch bleiben, wie man so hört.
Genau, und dann irgendwie Sachen, die in der Vorbereitung sind.
Also oben kann man ja dann auswählen, zeig mir mal alle Gesetzesvorhaben,
die in Vorbereitung sind. Kommt das schon aus dem Dip raus?
Nee, das ist der komplizierte Teil.
Ah, okay. Und wo kommt die dann her?
Die suche ich per Hand von den Seiten der Ministerien runter und trage die ein.
Okay. Das ist ein Spaß.
Das mache ich halt so einmal die Woche. Ich hatte verschiedene Ansätze,
das irgendwie zu automatisieren mit irgendwelchen Scrapern und hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber das war einfach komplett zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Zum einen, weil die Ministerien ungefähr alle halbe Jahr das Layout ihrer Webseiten komplett ändern.
Ja, das ist das eine Ding und es hat auch nicht jedes Ministerium eine dedizierte
Seite, wo diese ganzen laufenden Vorhaben sind,
also zum Beispiel Bildung und Forschung habe ich komplett aufgegeben,
das ist einfach eine Katastrophe.
Sie haben zwar eine Seite, aber da sind alle Gesetze aufgelistet,
die das Ministerium betreffen und dann schreiben sie irgendwie dazu,
wenn es dazu ein neues Änderungsgesetz gibt.
Also furchtbar. Also da gucke ich halt nicht mehr rein.
Bei anderen gibt es zwar irgendwie einen Link, aber da steht dann nichts und
dann hast du nur den Link zu dem PDF, also da gibt es dann keine richtige Seite.
Sehr gut macht es das Justizministerium, muss ich lobend erwähnen,
weil die haben dann so einen richtig schönen Verlauf, wo dann alle Dokumente
aufgelistet sind, alle Stellungnahmen und du so eine schöne Timeline hast und so.
Und eine Synopse mittlerweile sogar, ganz großartig.
Und so, ja, also das sind so die beiden Extreme eigentlich. Also dazwischen hast du alles Mögliche.
Jedes Ministerium macht es anders. Du hast da keine Einheitlichkeit.
Es wird ständig geändert. Und es sind auch nicht nur die Gesetze dort,
sondern auch alle Verordnungen, alle Beschlüsse und alle sonstigen Dokumente,
die irgendwie aus dem Ministerium kommen. Das heißt, du hast sehr viel Heu und
sehr wenig Stecknadeln.
Und das war dann einfach so eine Aufwand-Nutzen-Abwägung, weil für die zwei
Gesetzentwürfe, die dabei sind, dann müsste ich dann die ganzen 20 Verordnungen
dagegen jedes Mal wieder rauslöschen.
Und das hat sich dann nicht gerechnet.
Deswegen ist es für mich tatsächlich einfacher, wirklich einmal die Woche mich
hinzusetzen, alle Ministeriumseiten oder alle Vorhabenseiten da durchzugehen,
zu gucken, ob was Neues da ist und das dann einfach per Hand einzutragen.
Okay und das gilt dann auch noch für, also wenn man jetzt auf Gesetzesvorhaben
geht und sagt, sagen wir mal an, was in Vorbereitung ist,
dann gliedert sich das ja nochmal so in drei Phasen und sozusagen die früheste Phase,
die hier ist, sind so Eckpunkte, Papiere, das ist dann sozusagen das allererste,
was man überhaupt sieht, das kommt von den Webseiten.
Genau. Dafür Renten und Entwürfe sind dann auch noch, kommen auch noch von diesen Webseiten?
Genau, also eigentlich alles, was in Vorbereitung ist.
Einschließlich der Kabinettsbeschlüsse, also auch die sind nicht in diesem DIP mit drin.
Genau.
Okay.
Die sind auch ganz oft kein eigenes Dokument, sondern das ist dann der Referentenentwurf,
der halt jetzt nur vom ganzen Kabinett beschlossen wurde.
Also das ist meistens gar kein anderes Dokument.
Also das Kabinett ist sozusagen auch noch nicht digital, ist noch nicht maschinenlesbar.
Das hat nicht mal eine Webseite. Es hat eine Unterseite auf der Webseite bundesregierung.de.
Da gibt es eine Unterseite Kabinett und da stehen dann die Beschlüsse.
Okay. Manchmal.
Aber oft heißen sie dann auch anders als das Gesetz, das dann in den Bundestag kommt.
Aber der absolute Endgegner ist aber das Finanzministerium. Das muss ich unbedingt noch erzählen.
Das Finanzministerium hat nämlich die schöne Angewohnheit, die Links zu den
Vorhabenseiten zu ändern, wenn es eine Aktualisierung gab. weil das Datum der
Aktualisierung im Link enthalten ist.
Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn sich der Status ändert, sind meine Links alle hinfällig.
Oh Gott, oh Gott.
Willkommen in Deutschland.
Ja, dazu müsste es mal ein Gesetz geben, was?
Ja, das wäre super. Es steht im Koalitionsvertrag, und das war nämlich auch
einer der Auslöser, dass ich diesen Bundestagszusammenfasser dann irgendwann gemacht habe.
Es gibt einen Beschluss im Koalitionsvertrag, der sagt, wir wollen ein Gesetzgebungsportal.
Wo alle Gesetzesvorhaben aufgelistet sind mit Status und wo man den ganzen Verlauf
sehen kann und wo man eventuell auch kommentieren könnte.
Auf dieses Portal warte ich immer noch.
Du bist eigentlich das Portal.
Ich bin jetzt das Portal. Deswegen auch, denn irgendjemand muss es ja machen.
Genau, das ist die Tagline, denn irgendjemand muss es ja machen. Finde ich großartig.
Also ich muss sagen, das schafft einfach sofort Transparenz Ja,
Transparenz in gewisser Hinsicht, weil man sieht halt, was ist irgendwie hier von wo drin,
also könnte man sicherlich noch ein paar nette Features einbauen,
was weiß ich, das hier nach Ministerium zu sortieren oder irgendwie solche Filter,
aber davon unabhängig gehen wir mal nächsten Schritt.
Also in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt hier eines dieser Gesetze auswähle,
aus dieser Liste, egal in welchem Zustand die gerade sind, blendest du ja dann
auch noch so eine schöne Grafik ein, die so den theoretischen zukünftigen Verlauf abbildet.
Also was weiß ich hier, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, Gesetz zur Verbesserung
des Klimaschutzes beim Emissionsschutz und da geht es dann los mit einem Referentenentwurf,
dann hat es einen Kabinettsbeschluss gegeben,
dann ist das, ich vermute mal, wenn es sich so aufteilt, dann sind es zustimmungspflichtige
Gesetze durch den Bundesrat.
Das heißt man hat dann im Prinzip zwei parallele Verläufe,
ist im Bundesrat oder im Bundestag eingegangen und dann im Bundestag erste Lesung,
zweite und dritte Lesung beziehungsweise im Bundesrat ein erster Durchgang,
wie es da so schön heißt und eine potenzielle Beschlussfassung und dann wenn
beide zugestimmt haben, dann wird es halt auch verkündet, wenn es denn angenommen wurde.
Aber man sieht das hier sozusagen grafisch schon mal sehr schön.
Und dann gibt es als dritte Qualität sozusagen alles, was abgeschlossen ist,
also je nachdem, ob es abgelehnt oder gestoppt ist.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen abgelehnt und gestoppt?
Abgelehnt ist halt per Beschluss abgelehnt. Also da gab es einen Beschluss und sie waren dagegen.
Und gestoppt ist halt aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen. Zum Beispiel,
weil das Verfassungsgericht es für nichtig erklärt hat oder weil der Bundesrat
es halt erstmal auf Pause gesetzt hat.
Da hat es dann der Bundesrat abgelehnt, aber der Vorgang ist halt noch nicht komplett beendet.
Genau, wie zum Beispiel das Online-Zugangsgesetz, über das wollen wir bestimmt
auch gleich nochmal reden.
Also man kann aber hier auf jeden Fall jetzt sehen und das bezieht sich ja im
Prinzip alles jetzt, weil du hast ja quasi nur die aktuelle Legislaturperiode
bisher betrachtet, also alles was man hier sieht ist quasi jetzt die Arbeit
der aktuellen Legislatur.
Ich schätze mal nach der nächsten Wahl musst du dann auch noch die Legislaturperiode noch unterscheiden.
Ja, genau. Das ist mir auch leider siedend heiß ein paar Wochen später eingefallen.
Das ist ja irgendwann auch nochmal.
Irgendwann hat man nochmal die Vergangenheit am Hals.
Irgendwann muss ich ja nochmal die Legislaturperioden trennen. Ah, Mist.
Naja gut, ist ja noch relativ einfach. Derzeit sind sie alle noch in der gleichen.
Und wenn da so ein Warnsymbol dran steht, dann?
Dann gibt es einen Trojaner.
Dann gibt es einen Trojaner, genau. Und dafür hast du ja auch noch den passenden
Jingle immer am Start. Wenn das Pferd wiert, dann heißt das?
Dann heißt das, dass der Ausschuss, der über das Gesetz beraten hat,
da einfach noch Sachen mit angefügt hat, die mit dem Gesetz eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben.
Also der Bundestag nennt das Omnibus-Verfahren, ich nenne das Trojaner.
Das ist halt so eine beliebte Methode. Es ist eigentlich dafür gedacht,
dass man so Kleinigkeiten, so redaktionelle Änderungen,
Korrekturen von Verweisen oder sowas, dass man dafür nicht so ein komplettes
Gesetzgebungsverfahren machen muss, sondern das einfach im Rahmen einer Beschlussempfehlung
dann in die zweite, dritte Lesung bringt und dann den Bundestag darüber abstimmen lässt.
Es wird aber auch sehr gerne für andere Dinge benutzt.
Größere, viel größere.
Genau, und diese Dinge, die listest du dann auf. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt hier
so ein beschlossenes Gesetz hat,
Und der Trojaner-Check sagt, Achtung, Achtung, dann gibt es hier noch so ein
Hinweisfeld, wo dann eben all diese Dinge, die da noch mit reingeschrieben wurden,
die aber so auf den ersten Blick vielleicht mit dem Gesetzestitel oder Zweck
nichts zu tun hat, dann auch noch dabei sind.
Ja, das ist sehr schön. Das hast du ganz toll gemacht. Ja, weil das…,
Braucht man eigentlich und ich merke ja auch selber immer wieder und bin ja
im Prinzip auch nur so ein dahergelaufener Anfänger, der das irgendwie alles
mal ganz interessant findet.
Es gibt halt nicht so viele gute Ressourcen dafür, aber hier kann man dann eben
wirklich mal genau nachschlagen, so ja okay, was ist denn jetzt gerade mal im Busch.
Und wir haben das ja auch öfter in unserer Debatte, wenn so dieses Ding kommt
mit, oh, der Bundestag will jetzt nächste Woche das und das beschließen.
Und dann sind alle auf einmal ganz empört und dann werden Demos gestartet und so.
Und es ist dann halt, Leute, der Zug ist schon.
Der hat den Bahnhof nicht verlassen.
Der ist schon auf dem Abstellgleis und das gesamte Personal ist seit zwei Wochen im Urlaub.
Und das ist nicht der Zeitpunkt, wo man wirklich effizient Einfluss nehmen kann.
Und gerade jetzt hier auch mit den Gesprächen, die wir oft mit Thomas Lohninger
führen, der sich ja vor allem auf europäischer Ebene sehr viel engagiert.
Also es geht halt auch gerade bei diesem politischen Aktivismus oder sagen wir
mal Lobbyismus auch für die richtige Sache.
Darum einfach auch früh eine Nase dafür zu haben, was ist denn hier überhaupt im Busch.
Und das ist glaube ich sagen wir mal für Leute, die hier als Frühwarnsystem
auch fungieren wollen, gar nicht mal so doof.
Weil in dem Moment, wo so ein erstes Eckpunktepapier vorgelegt wird oder ein
Referentenentwurf, vielleicht kannst du nochmal den Unterschied nochmal kurz erklären.
In Eckpunktepapier ist noch kein wirklich ausformulierte Gesetzesänderung,
also da werden noch keine Paragraphen geändert,
sondern da wird einfach nur mal aufgelistet, was die Fraktion oder das Ministerium
gedenkt in einem Gesetzentwurf reinzuschreiben.
Okay.
Und der Referentenentwurf ist dann die tatsächliche Ausformulierung,
wo dann die wirklichen Paragraphen drinstehen.
Okay, verstehe. Genau, so und das kann man dann halt hier sehen und man sieht
halt irgendwie, okay, von wann ist das,
wer macht das so, Personen sehe ich jetzt selten oder nie, also in dem Sinne
sind auch nie wirklich Personen.
Nee, Personen sind auch nicht wirklich relevant.
Naja, wenn man mit jemandem reden will, vielleicht schon. und so, ne?
Ja, aber das weiß man halt nicht. Also die Ansprechpartner wären jetzt erstmal
die MinisterInnen halt, aber welche Referenten das jetzt sind,
das erfährt man halt nicht, das ist ja auch nicht öffentlich.
Okay. Steht auch selten in Dokumenten mit drin.
Ne, genau, also da steht es nie mit drin, ne.
Okay. Aber oft gibt es dann hier so einen Link zu dem Prozess auf der Webseite,
was du dann halt runtergescrebt hast und dann kann man ja gucken,
wer denn hier zu den den Fachgesprächen so alles eingeladen wurde und sich zu
dem Thema vielleicht geäußert hat, dann hat man ja auch schon mal eine Orientierung,
wohin die Reise hier vielleicht gehen könnte.
Ja, also das auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ganz gute Geschichte und.
Es ist insofern auch eine gute Ergänzung zum Podcast, weil der Podcast greift ja auch sehr spät ein.
Ich habe das da ja auch immer erst als Thema, wenn es eigentlich schon durch
ist, wie du gerade schon sagtest.
Wenn es eine Sitzungswoche ist.
Dann geht es eigentlich nur noch um die Beschlussfassung. Also außer es ist
Demokratiefördergesetz, dann liegt es halt noch mal ein Jahr.
Aber dann ist eigentlich die große Verhandlung ist dann schon beendet.
Und vor allem auch die zivilgesellschaftliche Beteiligung ist dann schon beendet.
Ja gut, also ich meine es ist zumindest schon mal ein ordentliches Verkündigungsportal.
Da hatten wir dann eben damals mit dem Bundesradio eben die andere Idee,
quasi in die Ausschüsse zu gehen und dann eben während das Ganze noch ausgecast
wird, zu dem Zeitpunkt eben schon zu berichten.
Weil in gewisser Hinsicht, gut man hat so ein Eckpunktepapier und man hat erste Pläne,
aber wenn es in den Bundestag geht,
dann geht es ja vor allem erstmal in die Ausschüsse.
Genau. Und da, das ist ja eigentlich der Ort, wo die Politik gemacht wird.
Ja, richtig.
Richtig. Und gut, das hast du ja auch hier.
Also wenn ich hier auswähle, okay, was ist im Bundestag, dann ist ja in der
Ausschussberatung auch eine Kategorie.
Und da wird es dann halt ganz interessant.
Und hier kann man ja sehen, okay, wie aktuell ist das? Hat sich hier in den
letzten drei Monaten irgendwas geändert?
Und hat hier überhaupt schon eine Anhörung stattgefunden oder nicht?
Und ja, das wäre natürlich auch cool, Cool, wenn man sowas dann auch gleich
mit Terminen, Ausschlussterminen oder sowas kombinieren könnte.
Das wäre super.
Wenn es die Informationen denn mal so maschinenlesbar gäbe.
Nein.
Genau.
Auch schon wieder Vollkatastrophe. Die Termine stehen in PDFs,
die halt dann verlinkt sind auf einer Unterseite von Bundestag.de.
Also muss man die ganzen PDFs durchklicken.
Aber du hast doch hier schon AI am Start.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich auch nochmal so ein Ding, was ich mir nochmal vornehmen
werde. dass ich versuche, diese PDFs irgendwie zu durchforsten.
Und hier sag mir mal die Termine, wann welches Gesetz beraten wird. Ähm ...
Ja, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ja, also eigentlich müsstest du vom Bundestag Schmerzensgeld gezahlt bekommen,
dafür, dass dieses angekündigte Portal noch nicht existiert.
Und zwar gestaffelt nach Parteien, hätte ich dann das gerne.
Heißt was? Einzelne Parteien müssen mehr zahlen?
Ja, ja, genau. Also manche Parteien müssen mehr Schmerzensgeld zahlen als andere.
Wer müsste denn da am meisten zahlen?
Ja, fünfmal darfst du raten. Ich kann dir sagen, wer am wenigsten zahlen muss,
am wenigsten muss nämlich die Linke zahlen, weil da gibt es nämlich einige Abgeordnete,
die auch regelmäßig aus Ausschusssitzungen berichten und hier zum Beispiel Anke
Domscheit-Berg hat einen eigenen Podcast,
wo sie regelmäßig mal so einen Einblick aus den Ausschüssen gibt,
sodass man das eben auch mitbekommt.
Das ist nämlich das große Problem bei den Ausschusssitzungen,
die Interessanten sind alle nicht öffentlich.
So, da kriegt man dann überhaupt nicht mit, was da besprochen wurde.
Und deswegen ist da, wie gesagt, wenn manche Abgeordnete da berichten,
dann ist das immer ganz hilfreich.
Ja, super. Kannst du denn Unterstützung gebrauchen? Brauchst du technische Unterstützung oder?
Aber am meisten bräuchte ich eigentlich grafische Unterstützung.
Ja. Also technisch auch ein bisschen, aber ich finde es halt nicht hübsch.
Aber ich kann nicht hübsch.
Also ich bin so grafik- und designtechnisch bin ich einfach komplett talentfrei.
Und ich sehe, dass es nicht gut aussieht, aber ich weiß nicht,
wie ich es hübsch kriege.
Also ich muss sagen, da habe ich jetzt wenig zu kritisieren.
Das ist funktional und übersichtlich und schreit einen nicht an.
Ich hätte es gerne noch hübscher. Also wenn es jemanden gibt,
der da irgendwie nochmal ein etwas anderes Auge drauf hat und auch weiß,
wie man das umsetzen kann, gerne melden.
Und was so Features und so weiter betrifft?
Features auf jeden Fall eben noch die, was wir gerade schon sagten,
die Termine der Ausschüsse würde ich total gerne mit drin haben.
Und ja, auch noch so Komfortabilitätsfunktionen, halt filtern,
sortieren und so weiter in den ganzen Tabellen und Übersichten.
Oder dass man noch eine erweiterte Suche sozusagen, dass man die Suche noch
mal mehr eingrenzen kann.
Weil im Moment kann man ja einfach nur irgendeinen Begriff eingeben,
aber keine Filter setzen oder so.
Also es wäre jetzt bei der Menge vielleicht auch noch nicht so super relevant,
weil die Anzahl der Suchergebnisse hält sich in Grenzen.
Aber spätestens wenn es dann auf eine nächste Legislatur geht,
wäre es auf jeden Fall da gut, wenn es dann noch Filtermöglichkeiten gäbe.
Okay, also wenn dir da jemand helfen möchte, dann er oder sie sich melden. Alles klar. Gut.
Wie und wo steht auch auf der Seite unter unterstützen.
Genau, das verlinke ich auch alles, das findet ihr hier in den Shownotes.
Gut, jetzt würde ich natürlich ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen dein gewonnenes
Wissen ein bisschen abfragen.
Jetzt kommt der Test, Hefte raus, Klassenarbeit.
Genau das. Ja, nee, also ich meine, ich muss zugeben, dass ich mich nicht im
Ansatz so intensiv mit dieser Frage beschäftigt habe immer, was kommt eigentlich woher.
Und ich glaube, du hast schon ein ganz gutes Verständnis dafür entwickelt,
welches Gesetz jetzt eigentlich worauf konkret wirklich eine Auswirkung hat
oder gehabt hat oder haben wird, mehr oder weniger wahrscheinlich.
Was sind denn sozusagen gerade die Gesetze, die eigentlich im Wesentlichen oder
am meisten das beeinflussen,
wie der Staat einerseits selbst digital funktioniert und andererseits regelt,
was bei uns mit dem Digitalen so läuft?
Ja, genau, da muss man ganz klar trennen.
Ich fange mal mit dem Bereich an, wie das Digitale funktioniert,
weil das ist deutlich übersichtlicher.
Weil da gibt es im Wesentlichen so fünf Gesetze, auf die man so gucken kann und sollte.
Das erste wäre das Telekommunikationsgesetz, also das TKG. Das regelt im Prinzip
alles, was so die eigentliche Infrastruktur ist.
Also das Kabel, so für die Netzwerke, so alles bis Layer 4, glaube ich, ungefähr. Ja.
Also wer was darf, welche Marktteilnehmer
es da gibt, welche Rechte die haben, wer die Aufsicht macht,
was die machen müssen an Genehmigungsverfahren und so weiter,
das steht alles im Telekommunikationsgesetz, also zu Themen wie Netzneutralität
oder so, da wäre das so das relevante Gesetz.
Dann gibt es so Layer 7, also alles was so Dienste angeht, da ist das neue große
Gesetz das Digitale-Dienste-Gesetz.
Das ist ja die deutsche Umsetzung des Digital Services Act.
Ja.
Der ist noch nicht ganz durch, der muss noch durch den Bundesrat,
also das digitale Dienstegesetz.
Das wird aber wahrscheinlich dann jetzt Ende April passieren.
Und das löst dann erstmal das Telemediengesetz ab, das war vorher für solche Sachen zuständig.
Da ist dann halt geregelt, was halt Anbieter von Diensten so dürfen.
Und zwar alle möglichen Dienste. Also es gilt sowohl für so Hetzner und 1&1,
aber auch für Lieferando beispielsweise.
Also alle, die irgendwie auf diesem Netz irgendwelche Dienstleistungen anbieten
und dann auch was die dürfen, wie die das machen müssen, welche Pflichten sie haben,
wem sie irgendwas berichten müssen, wer die Aufsicht hat und diese Dinge.
Das gilt ja im Prinzip auch für alle, die eine Webseite haben.
Ja, es gibt da irgendwie so eine Untergrenze oder so. Also erstmal muss es halt gewerblich sein.
Also man muss irgendwie Geld damit verdienen, glaube ich. Lage mich nicht fest.
In den Details stecke ich immer nicht so drin. Ich bin mehr für den groben Überblick zuständig.
Das ist ja auch das, worauf wir uns jetzt konzentrieren wollen.
Genau. Also es gibt aber auf jeden Fall so eine, nicht jeder,
der eine Webseite hat, hat jetzt direkt irgendwelche Berichtspflichten oder
sowas. Also das gilt dann nur für Leute, die da wirklich ein größeres...
Die Meta-Ebene muss da schon mal reinschauen. Gesetz über digitale Dienste heißt
das ja offiziell. Genau. Über.
Ja, das klingt auf jeden Fall besser als Telemediengesetz, weil unter Telemediengesetz
kann sich noch weniger Leute was darunter vorstellen, glaube ich.
Genau, das wäre so das. Dann gibt es noch das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Das wird auch zu sehr großen Teilen vom Digitale Dienste abgelöst.
Ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt auch nicht, warum sie es überhaupt nicht komplett
integriert haben, weil eigentlich ist da nicht mehr viel von übrig.
Da stehen jetzt noch ein paar Definitionen und ein paar Bußgeldvorschriften
drin, aber ansonsten ist das komplett entkernt.
Das regelte dann eher so Layer 8, also alles, was Leute und User denn so dürfen.
Und da sind wir beim Thema Hassrede, Beleidigung online und so weiter.
Aber auch das ist jetzt eben in das digitale Dienstegesetz alles mit rübergewandert.
Deswegen, also Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz können wir eigentlich vergessen.
Und dann gibt es noch den Medienstaatsvertrag, der ist für dich und auch für
mich sogar noch relevanter,
weil der regelt ja alle journalistischen und sonst wie Angebote gemäß einem Sendeplan.
Und da ist dann diese ganze Regulierung drin, was man darf und was man halt nicht darf, genau.
Wo du gerade sagst, Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz,
Das ist auch lustig, je nachdem wie man es betont, bedeutet das was anderes.
Also ein Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist was anderes als ein Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Genau.
Die Frage ist, was ist es denn jetzt eigentlich?
Wer soll hier eigentlich was im Netz haben?
Aber da fiel mir gerade jetzt noch eine andere Herausforderung sozusagen für
einen Bundestagszusammenfasser 5.0 ein, sozusagen,
also im Idealfall will man ja auch digital einen Überblick über alle Gesetze
haben, also den, den du sozusagen hast.
Also nicht nur, was gerade entsteht, sondern eben auch, was existiert und im
Idealfall eben auch so, was ist von was abgelöst worden.
Und dann ist irgendwas auch nicht mehr gültig und so.
Fällt mir nur gerade so nebenbei noch mit ein, dass das ja auch so ein Aspekt
eigentlich einer Digitalisierung des Staates selbst ist.
Da gibt es aber ein paar schöne Quellen.
Also einmal gibt es Buzer oder Buzer, ich weiß nicht, wie er sich ausspricht, B-U-Z-E-R.de,
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Mensch, der das betreibt, dem wir auch,
also dem ich sehr dankbar bin.
Buzer.de Und der hat tatsächlich, ich glaube, es ist ein R, irgendwas stand da.
Auf der Seite gibt es jedenfalls tatsächlich alle Gesetze und Verordnungen und
eben auch mit Synopsen, also mit DIVs zwischen den verschiedenen Versionen.
Kannst du mir nochmal die URL sagen, weil die, die ich hier gerade eingegeben
habe, die ist es bestimmt nicht.
B-U-Z-E-R-D-E.
Ah, mit einem Z, alles klar. Genau, Buzerre.
Buzerre.
Okay, alles klar. Ah ja, Bundesrecht, tagesaktuell konsolidiert,
alle Fassungen seit 2006.
Richtig.
Okay.
Dem alle ganz viel Geld werfen. Bitte. Danke.
Okay. Also da sind sozusagen alle Gesetze aufgeführt. Ja. Okay.
Und wie gesagt, auch mit dem Vergleich, du kannst dich da durch die Versionen
durchklicken, wann welcher Paragraf von wem geändert wurde und so. Das ist echt mega.
Okay. Mit vielen Abkürzungen auf jeden Fall auch.
Ja, der Aküphi in der Bundespolitik oder in der Politik ist sehr weit verbreitet.
Oh man, das ist aber auch wirklich erschlagend vollständig hier.
Einschließlich einer Information zur...
Gedenkmütze Eva Fußball Europameisterschaft 2024.
Ich möchte auch eine Gedenkmütze haben.
Super.
Das ist auch eine Merch-Idee, Mensch. Logpolitik, Netzpolitik, Gedenkmütze.
Ja, okay. Ich würde es mal erwägen. Alles klar.
Okay. Okay, buzer.de, super Tipp, alles klar.
Dann schauen wir doch mal vielleicht auf die anderen Aspekte,
nämlich was sozusagen regelt, was der Staat denn eigentlich so tun sollte.
Das ist, jetzt wird es richtig kompliziert, weil jetzt kann man nicht sagen,
es gibt diese fünf oder auch nur diese zehn Gesetze oder so,
die das regeln, sondern das sind alle.
Also da reden wir wirklich von hunderten verschiedenen Gesetzen,
in denen einzelne Paragraphen stehen, die einmal das regeln,
wie digital Behörden arbeiten.
Das ist dann immer jeweils das Gesetz zu der Behörde oder zu dem Ressort, zu dem das gehört.
Und da sind es dann bestimmte Verwaltungsvorschriften, die eben regeln,
dass sie irgendwas auf Papier haben müssen oder dass sie irgendwas elektronisch machen dürfen.
Und dann gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe Gesetze, wo drinsteht,
dass zum Beispiel die Wirtschaft irgendwas auf Papier oder elektronisch irgendwie machen darf.
Ein schönes Beispiel dafür ist jetzt eigentlich das Bürokratieentlastungsgesetz,
das jetzt demnächst kommen soll, weil das soll ja die Wirtschaft von Bürokratie entlasten, angeblich.
Nicht die Bürokratie selbst entlasten.
Nee, nee, auch. Nee, es soll, erstmal soll es hauptsächlich,
also Christian Lindner sagt, es soll hauptsächlich die Wirtschaft entlasten.
Sagen wir es mal so. Okay. Und diese Entlastung besteht fast im Wesentlichen
darin, dass in ungefähr 50 verschiedenen Paragraphen die Schriftform durch die Textform ersetzt wird,
sodass du Sachen dann nicht mehr auf Papier machen musst, sondern sie dann auch
elektronisch machen kannst.
Mhm.
Genau, so ähnlich funktionierte es dann auch, sowas ähnliches war auch schon
im Wachstumschancengesetz so ein bisschen enthalten, da waren auch dann hier
und da dann zum Beispiel die E-Rechnung, die mit dem Wachstumschancengesetz
jetzt verabschiedet wurde.
Das ist halt eine Änderung im Umsatzsteuergesetz.
Und zwar bei der Definition, was eine formal korrekte Rechnung ist.
Und die wurde jetzt geändert, sodass auch E-Rechnungen und elektronische Rechnungen
in einem strukturierten Format auch als formal korrekte Rechnungen gelten.
Das begrüße ich im Übrigen besonders.
Ich extrem auch, ja.
Das wird echt mal Zeit.
Ich freue mich sehr, ja.
Okay.
Genau, und so geht das halt weiter. Also im Grunde kannst du fast jedes Gesetz
durchgehen und du wirst irgendeinen Paragrafen finden, der Digitalisierung verhindert, glaube ich.
Oder auch jetzt Digitalisierung der Justiz.
Es gibt einmal ein Gesetz, das heißt Digitalisierung der Justiz und dann gibt
es noch fünf andere Gesetze, die auch irgendwas mit Digitalisierung im Bereich
der Justiz ändern. dann.
Eins zum Beispiel, dass Videokonferenzen in Zivilprozessen ermöglicht,
dann gibt es noch eins, dass digitale Dokumentation von,
Moment, jetzt muss ich gerade, Strafgerichtsprozessen,
genau, das war Strafgerichtsprozesse, regelt und dann gibt es eben nochmal das
Digitalisierung der Justiz, wo dann eben nochmal diverse andere Paragraphen
geändert werden, wo dann auch irgendwas digitalisiert werden soll.
Und so geht das, so kannst du in jeden Bereich reingucken und es ist unfassbar gleichwertig.
Und das sind jetzt nicht Gesetze in dem Sinne, sondern das sind Änderungspakete an vielen Gesetzen.
Genau, das sind dann Änderungspakete an diversen, teilweise Gesetzen,
teilweise Verordnungen, teilweise irgendwelchen Behörden, Verwaltungsvorschriften.
Und ja, genau, das sind ja dann immer diese Artikelgesetze oder diese Änderungsgesetze
halt, die dann kein eigenes Stammgesetz sind.
Ist das der richtige Begriff? Änderungspaket oder Änderungsgesetz?
Änderungsgesetz ist eigentlich das. Entweder Änderungsgesetz oder Artikelgesetz
ist, glaube ich, so ein Fachbegriff.
Und die großen Gesetze, das sind dann die Stammgesetze.
Also das Telekommunikationsgesetz ist zum Beispiel ein Stammgesetz.
Ah, verstehe. Das steht dann so für sich.
Änderungsgesetz oder Novelle, genau.
Ja, Novelle wird auch viel benutzt.
Stammgesetz, wieder was gelernt.
Ja, man muss ja auch was haben, mit dem man auch angeben kann in der Küche auf der Party.
Ja, genau.
Das Einzige, was es da tatsächlich als großes Gesetz gibt, ist das Online-Zugangsgesetz,
das ja jetzt auch gerade gestoppt wurde. Wir hatten es vorhin,
glaube ich, schon mal kurz erwähnt.
Ja, erzähl mal, warum, also was ist denn da?
Ach ja.
Wie stehst du dir dazu? Ich habe rausgehört, dass du da eine Meinung zu hast.
Ach, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen. Ja, also der Bundesrat,
nein, ich muss weiter vorne anfangen.
Das ist ja schon die zweite Version des Online-Zugangsgesetzes.
Es gab das ja schon mal 2017, das war das Online-Zugangsgesetz 1.
Und jetzt, das sollte eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass alle Verwaltungsleistungen
des Bundes und auch der Länder und Kommunen dann irgendwann mal digital werden.
Also, dass du für deine, keine Ahnung, die Geburtsurkunde deines Kindes nicht
mehr dann da hin musst, na doch, dafür schon, aber egal, sondern dass du das
irgendwie online beantragen kannst. Klar.
So, das hat, sagen wir, nicht so gut funktioniert und deswegen gab es dann jetzt
in diesem Jahr das Online-Zugangsgesetz 2.
Das sollte dafür sorgen, dass das jetzt dann doch tatsächlich mal passiert.
So, das hat der Bundestag beschlossen und hat es verabschiedet und der Bundesrat
hat es jetzt aber abgelehnt.
Und im Moment hängt das in so einem Schwebezustand und wartet darauf,
dass die Bundesregierung oder der Bundestag jetzt den Vermittlungsausschuss
anrufen, damit da die Verhandlungen weitergehen können.
Jetzt habe ich übrigens mal ganz parallel, einfach nur mal so zum Testen,
habe ich im Bundestagszusammenfasser einfach mal Online-Zugang eingegeben und
bin dann sofort auf Online-Zugangsgesetz 2.0 gestoßen worden,
draufgeklickt und sehe jetzt genau in dieser grafischen Übersicht,
hätte alles funktionieren können, wenn nicht am Ende Bundesratbeschlussfassung
einen roten Punkt bekommen hätte. Ja. Ganz toll.
Genau. Der Bundesrat ist nämlich der Meinung, dass das für die Länder eine völlig
unzumutbare Belastung ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das tatsächlich ernst gemeint ist oder ob das auch wieder
nur Verhandlungsmasse für ein anderes Gesetz ist. Das habe ich nicht so ganz verfolgt gerade.
Da hatte ich gerade wieder so eine Phase, wo ich mir das alles nicht anhören konnte.
Aber das ist so, das ist das, was zumindest nach außen getragen wird,
dass es halt für die Länder zu aufwendig ist, die fristen alle viel zu kurz,
so jetzt ganz plötzlich kommen die auf einmal mit Digitalisierung aus dem Nichts.
Aus dem Nichts, hätte ja keiner mit rechnen können.
Da konnte keiner mit rechnen, da konnte sich auch keiner drauf vorbereiten.
Okay.
Ja und jetzt hängt es da und wir warten.
Und denkst du denn, dass die Regelungen, wie sie dort besprochen wurden,
wirklich jetzt den Ländern zu viel zugemutet hätten?
Ob du eine Sicht drauf hast, was eigentlich jetzt der beste Weg wäre,
diese Digitalisierung des Staates zu erreichen?
Also der beste Weg wäre, wenn wir einfach nochmal 20 Jahre zurückspulen ungefähr
und dann der Bund, also auf Bundesebene, auf bundespolitischer Ebene,
ein großer Verwaltungsanwendung App Store aufgesetzt wird Und einmal diese ganzen
verschiedenen Fachanwendungen, die dann benötigt werden,
beschafft oder programmieren lässt oder was auch immer. Also je nachdem,
ob es das schon gibt oder nicht.
Und die dann den Kommunen bereitstellt. Und zwar so, dass gleich als komplettes Ökosystem,
mehr oder weniger komplettes Ökosystem, aber zumindest mit kompatiblen Schnittstellen,
das geplant wird und dann eben an die Kommunen verteilt wird und die sich dann
das so zusammenbauen können, wie die das brauchen.
So, dass die Kommunen eben erstmal diese ganze Beschaffung nicht in ihrem Bereich
haben, dass sie den Support nicht in ihrem Bereich haben, die Administration
und vor allem auch die Schulung.
Weil das ist jetzt, im Moment ist es halt so aufgesetzt, jede Kommune und jedes
Land muss im Prinzip die Fachanwendung für ihre Behörden selber beschaffen.
Die müssen selber ein Software-Auswahlverfahren machen, die müssen das selber
installieren, die müssen es teilweise selber beauftragen oder tatsächlich erstellen lassen.
Sie müssen ihre Leute irgendwie selber schulen und jede Kommune muss das selber
machen. Also du hast diesen Overhead einfach mal 400 oder so. so.
Und das ist halt einfach, und die Sachen funktionieren dann nicht miteinander,
also du kannst dann nicht Daten einfach übertragen, so jemand zieht um von Bayern
nach Schleswig-Holstein, du kannst nicht einfach dessen Meldedatensatz oder
dessen Finanzamtsdatensatz.
Steuerdatensatz übertragen an die andere Behörde, sondern du musst dann an deinem
neuen Wohnort den kompletten Anmeldeprozess und so weiter, musst du halt alles nochmal selber machen.
Weil einfach die Schnittstellen nicht untereinander funktionieren.
Also Kommunen haben wir ja so fast 11.000 Gemeinden. Du meinst wahrscheinlich so Landkreise.
Ich war bei Landkreisen.
Genau, auf der Ebene. Aber das ist natürlich ein guter Punkt.
Und interessant finde ich jetzt auch deine Stoßrichtung, weil ich frage mich
halt auch immer schon die ganze Zeit, was,
Was brauchst du halt eigentlich? Und andere Länder haben ja auch Digitalministerien,
die in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein wenig durchregieren können,
so ähnlich wie es halt das Finanzministerium tun kann.
Und ich finde, so wie man beim Geld einen Überblick haben muss,
müsste man halt eigentlich auch bei dem Digitalen einen Überblick haben.
Und ich glaube, das ist so in
der Politiker-Mentalität in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig angekommen.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht haben wir es ja gerade hergeleitet.
Also dieses, wenn du den Staat digitalisieren willst, dann musst du quasi in
jedem Absatz irgendwo sagen, muss aber auch ohne Papier gehen,
muss aber so gehen, muss aber so gehen.
Und ich kann das dann auch gut verstehen, wenn jetzt so ein Landkreis die Hände
hebt und sagt, habt ihr sie noch alle? Wir können doch jetzt nicht hier für
jeden Landkreis das Rad immer wieder neu erfinden.
Klar, es gibt natürlich Gesetzesunterschiede, pipapo,
auf Landesebene und sicherlich gibt es auch noch irgendwas,
was der eine Landkreis anders macht als der andere,
weil die ja in gewisser Hinsicht in der konkreten Umsetzung ihrer Anwendungen
und so weiter dann auch nochmal so andere Methodiken haben oder keine Ahnung,
Prozesse, Abläufe, Zuständigkeiten.
Nur, das ist ja nun absolut zumutbar, dass man Software entwickelt,
die im Prinzip für 400 Landkreise dann eben auch die entsprechenden Anpassungen
auch vornimmt oder zumindest so parametrisierbar macht.
Aber dann in dem Moment, wo man sagt, naja, ihr müsst aber jetzt hier ein bestimmtes
Datenformat, nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel elektronische Rechnung,
muss ja jetzt von allen unterstützt werden,
macht ja einfach keinen Sinn, das auch nur mehr als einmal zu implementieren.
Richtig. Es ist ja schon schlimm genug, dass es auf EU-Ebene ja schon wieder
unterschiedliche Formate gibt.
Also wenn du Internationalrechnungen schickst, dann hast du ja auch gleich wieder ein Problem.
Ja, ist nicht ganz so schlimm. Ich habe mir das nämlich gerade mal angeschaut
mit den elektronischen Rechnungen.
Also tatsächlich gibt es einen europäischen Standard.
Ich glaube, da sind wir auf dem richtigen Weg. Aber definitiv innerhalb von
Deutschland noch nicht, was die Digitalisierung betrifft.
Und selbst wenn es jetzt kein Digitalministerium gibt, was ich denke,
was es geben sollte, was es halt auf jeden Fall braucht, ist halt eine Bundessoftwareschmiede.
Also eigentlich muss man eben diese ganze Softwareentwicklung,
zumindest die Koordinierung davon, in die eigene Hand nehmen.
Dass man einfach an einer Stelle für den gesamten Staat das koordiniert.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass jetzt ein eigenes Software-Team für jeden Fall angestellt
werden muss. Die Leute werden sie gar nicht bekommen.
Aber zumindest eben zu sagen, okay hier Firma X, ihr werdet jetzt beauftragt,
hier diesen Teil noch beizutragen.
Aber wir entwickeln halt jetzt einfach Software für Deutschland und die dann
halt überall zur Anwendung kommen und das muss dann eben auch funktionieren
und hier sind die Anforderungen etc. pp.
Ja, genau. Man kann es ja auch dann so konfigurierbar machen,
dass es eben auch für die verschiedenen Landesgesetzgebungen passt und so.
Der eine hat dann irgendwie, der fragt dann noch die Sachen ab oder so,
aber das kann man sich ja dann, das kann man ja einbauen.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht, man muss das ja nur einmal aufnehmen.
Wenn irgendwas anpassbar ist, dann ist es Software.
Ja, eben. Also muss man einfach nur das Anforderungsprofil vernünftig schreiben.
Ach ja.
So, das wäre so der Idealzustand. Und man könnte auch,
sag ich zumindest als juristische Laien, ich bin auch immer noch nicht überzeugt
davon, dass es wirklich erforderlich ist, in jedem einzelnen Paragrafen dazu
zu schreiben, ach übrigens, das geht jetzt auch digital.
Ich bin immer noch der festen Überzeugung,
man könnte das auch einfach als Generalklausel irgendwo machen.
So Schriftform bedeutet auch E-Mail zum Beispiel oder irgendwie sowas.
Also gibt es wahrscheinlich juristische Spitzfindigkeiten, warum das jetzt total nicht geht.
Aber irgendwie glaube ich, dass da auch sehr viel Nicht-Wollen dabei ist.
Ja und was wahrscheinlich auch viel mit immer noch mit nicht so wirklich Verstehen auch zu tun hat.
Ja, genau. Und es wird dann auch immer gerne auf die gängige Rechtspraxis verwiesen,
was ja auch nur hochgestochen ist für, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Genau, haben wir immer schon so gemacht.
Und die Widerstände sind in vielen Bereichen halt auch sehr groß.
Jetzt zum Beispiel, da sind wir wieder beim Gesetz Digitalisierung der Justiz,
da soll es unter anderem darum gehen, dass Strafanträge auch online gestellt werden können.
Und ich kann noch mal einen Link raussuchen, den wir vielleicht in die Shownotes packen können.
Es gibt einen Beitrag auf LinkedIn, wo Marco Buschmann, also der Justizminister,
dieses Gesetz vorgestellt hat mit so ein paar Erklärbildchen.
Und es haben sich diverse RichterInnen und AnwältInnen unter diesem Beitrag
halt geäußert, wie schlimm sie diesen Vorschlag finden.
Und wie doch dann der Strafantrag dadurch an Wert verliert.
Und das fand ich auch sehr bemerkenswert irgendwie.
Also da schrieb dann eine Rechtsanwältin, eine eigenhändige Unterschrift markiert
eine Zäsur und regt zum eigenständigen Denken an, ob man den Strafantrag überhaupt möchte.
Also wenn du das, das ist so diese Wertigkeit, die dann da oft ist und diese
Befürchtungen, die da oft kommen.
Ja, wenn du das online machst, dann ist das nichts wert, das ist ja nichts Echtes.
Und das kommt in ganz vielen Kommentaren kommt das da durch.
Und das ist so, ich glaube das sind halt so die Widerstände mit denen du dann
auf allen Ebenen dann auch zu kämpfen hast und das sind natürlich dann auch,
wenn wir von RichterInnen und RechtsanwältInnen reden das sind dann auch die,
die auch viel Einfluss haben auf die Politik und darauf, wie dann die Gesetze.
Geschrieben werden für ihren Bereich die sind da stark in den Verbänden allein schon.
Weil der halbe Bundestag sind ja Juristen. Ja, ach ja.
Also ich muss sagen, bei den Juristen kann ich auch schnell nachtragend werden,
weil ich ja eigentlich finde, dass so Softwareentwicklung und Juristerei,
dann doch recht verwandte Themenbereiche sind in der Art und Weise,
wie man eigentlich über sein Material nachzudenken hat.
Weil irgendwie Code zu schreiben und Software zu entwickeln und Systeme zu entwickeln
bedeutet ja auch, ein Verständnis,
zu entwickeln von der eigentlichen Sachlage und Problematik und den Lösungsvorschlägen
und das dann eben mit Code beantwortet und in der Juristerei ist es ja nun eigentlich
ähnlich dahingehend, dass man ja auch hier eine Bestandsaufnahme macht und sagt,
wir hätten das jetzt aber gerne so und um das sicherzustellen,
dass diese Prozesse dann in
Zukunft auch so laufen, entwickeln wir jetzt hier dieses Gesetz, was eben,
definiert, klar macht, was eigentlich sein soll und ich verstehe immer nicht,
wie man dann einfach den Brückenschluss zu digitales Gut nicht hinkriegen kann.
Ja, das kann ich auch nicht nachvollziehen. Eigentlich ist es fast dasselbe.
Eigentlich ist es doch ganz einfach.
Ja, weil ich glaube, ich habe so Theorien, ich habe da ja auch in meinem Berufsleben,
halt jeden Tag mit zu tun, halt mit diesen ganzen Widerständen, die da kommen.
Weil ich eben auch bei mir in der Firma dann die ganzen Digitalisierungsprojekte,
begleite. Das ist halt auch,
Einfach viel Verlustängste auch, dass man etwas, was einem vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen identitätsstiftend ist, was auf jeden Fall einen Wert hat,
dass man das verliert oder dass man liebgewonnene Aufgaben verliert.
Oder dass eben die eigene Arbeit keinen Wert mehr hat, weil es jetzt viel einfacher ist.
Und das sind so...
Die deutsche Angst.
Ja, das sind die deutsche Angst, ja. Ja. Wenn es zu einfach ist und so,
dann ist das nichts Richtiges.
Ja.
Wenn deine Arbeit dir Spaß macht, dann arbeitest du gar nicht wirklich.
Lass uns mal weg vom Digitalen hin zur realen Welt kommen, ohne die Welt der
Gesetze komplett zu verlassen.
Es gab ja jetzt ein Gesetz, was gerade beschlossen wurde, habe ich jetzt auch
gleich mal im Bundestagszusammenfassern nochmal nachgeschlagen, nach Cannabis gesucht.
Und ich finde sofort, das Gesetz zum kontrollierten Umgang mit Cannabis ist
verkündet, im Gesetzblatt verkündet und von daher halt gültig.
Letzte Änderung vom 22.03.
Und wir wissen alle, am 1.
April ist es ja dann auch schon zu den ersten öffentlichen Kiffereien gekommen.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich auch etwas intensiver begleitet, oder?
Das fand ich sehr lustig. Ich hatte sehr viel Spaß bei diesem Gesetz.
Und ganz ohne Cannabis. Okay.
Warum?
Unfassbar. Und das war so bizarr einfach, dass ich da sehr viel Spaß dran hatte.
Also man muss das mit so einem Abstand gucken. So nach dem Motto,
es betrifft mich eh nicht.
Dann kann man sich ein bisschen drüber amüsieren. Okay. Also das war schon...
Ein Highlight deutscher Bürokratiekultur.
Okay. Ja, also was sagt der,
Bundestagszusammenfasser? Also vielleicht auch nochmal, ich wollte das auch
nochmal aufgreifen, um einfach mal so ein Beispiel zu liefern.
Also zum Gesetz, abgesehen davon, dass ich ja die Basics bekomme mit was jetzt
gerade der Status ist, hast du ja dann diese Zusammenfassung mit GPT-4.
Und ich finde das einfach immer wieder bemerkenswert, wie gut diese LLMs an
der Stelle wirklich behilflich sein können.
Also Textzusammenfassungen können die echt richtig gut.
Genau. Und das ist auch tatsächlich ein guter Weg.
Ich habe das auch gemerkt, also immer wenn, keine Ahnung, also so Gesetze ist
das eine und so wissenschaftliche Paper ist das andere.
Ich meine, wenn ich hier so ein wissenschaftliches Paper für keine Ahnung was
für einen Bereich vor die Nase bekomme, dann weiß ich schon,
wenn das nicht mein Feld ist, dann brauche ich erst gar nicht anfangen,
über den Abstract nennenswert hinauszugehen.
Aber sich das halt mit so einem LLM zusammenzufassen und dann immer noch die Möglichkeit zu haben,
danach Fragen zu stellen, ob das da drin ist oder nicht oder was das dann bedeutet
und was da für Regelungen sind, das ist einfach großartig.
Das wäre übrigens auch noch ein cooles Feature für den Bundestagszusammenfasser.
Dann so gleich so ein eingebauter Chatbot, dass man sich mit dem Gesetz unterhalten kann.
Das wäre in der Tat Ja.
Mega. Da bräuchte ich aber dann doch jemanden, weil da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Ja okay, das ist ja sicherlich ein interessantes Feld.
Du hast es ja hier schon aufgebrochen in verschiedenste Bereiche,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also es ist immer dieselbe Struktur hier, so Inkrafttreten, Hintergrund,
Kosten etc. Das heißt, man kriegt zum Beispiel schnell eine Liste mit,
welche Maßnahmen stecken denn jetzt eigentlich in diesem Gesetz tatsächlich drin.
Und hier haben wir dann Entkriminalisierung des Eigenkonsums von Cannabis bis
zu 25 Gramm, Einführung eines Werbe- und Sponsoringverbots für Konsum-Cannabis,
Durchführung von Modellvorhaben für die gewerbliche Produktion und Vertrieb von Cannabis,
Einführung des Medizinal-Cannabis-Gesetzes und Lockerung bürokratischer Vorgaben
im Bereich Medizinal-Cannabis und Evaluation der Gesetzesauswirkungen nach vier Jahren.
Und eins habe ich jetzt weggelassen, weil darüber wollten wir jetzt mal genauer sprechen.
Ermöglichung des privaten und gemeinschaftlichen Eigenanbaus von Cannabis in Anbauvereinigungen.
Und das ist ja so ein kleiner Stolperstein jetzt sozusagen für die Bürger,
weil, tja, wenn man also quasi selber jetzt Hanf anpflanzen möchte,
weil irgendwo muss man es ja herbekommen.
Bei Eigenkonsum ist ja jetzt inkriminalisiert, aber es gibt ja nach wie vor
keinen Ort, wo man es kaufen kann sozusagen.
Es gibt ja keine Vertriebserlaubnis dafür und stellt sich halt wieder die Frage,
ja okay, was heißt denn das jetzt?
Und Netzpolitik.org hat es ja auch in einem Begriff sehr schön zusammengefasst,
so beim Dealer gibt es halt besseren Datenschutz.
Das ist richtig. Die Datensammelei in den Anbauvereinigungen ist schon nicht ohne.
Also die haben halt echt ausufernde Berichtspflichten von Daten,
die sie halt erfassen müssen von ihren Mitgliedern.
Also vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal überhaupt erklärt hattet
irgendwie mit dem, wie das jetzt überhaupt funktioniert hier.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja so, anbauen darf man in einem Anbauverein.
Das heißt also, um Cannabis anbauen zu dürfen, in Größe, also mit mehr als drei
Pflanzen, musst du halt Mitglied eines Vereins sein. Nein, dieser Verein muss,
wie ich eben schon sagte, wahnsinnig viele Auflagen erfüllen.
Unter anderem müssen sie eben auch von all ihren Mitgliedern aufzeichnen und
festhalten, dokumentieren, wer wann
wie viel Cannabis abgenommen hat oder Vermehrungsmaterial, je nachdem.
Und ja, das müssen sie für fünf Jahre vorhalten. Die zuständige Kontrollbehörde
darf das auch im Rahmen einer jährlichen Kontrolle, also die wirklich jährlich
stattfinden soll, auch einsehen.
Sie dürfen Kopien davon anfertigen und sie dürfen es bei Bedarf,
wenn sie irgendwie den Verdacht haben, dass irgendwas nicht in Ordnung ist,
dann dürfen sie es halt auch mitnehmen.
Und dann dürfen sie es auch anderen Behörden weitergeben. Das ist auch schön.
Und ich glaube, die Einstiegshürde dafür sind sogar Ordnungswidrigkeiten.
Die Einstiegshürde sind Ordnungswidrigkeiten, korrekt. Also selbst für ein Parkticket
oder so könnten sie dann die Daten an die Polizei weitergeben. gegeben.
Falsch geparkt? Tja, Pech gehabt. Dann werden die Daten abgerufen.
Tja, also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr fragwürdig und da sieht man mal auch wieder
schön, wie schwer sich Deutschland doch mit Änderungen so tut.
Weil ich meine, das wird ja nun alles schon so lange diskutiert und das Ziel
dieses Gesetzes ist ja eigentlich, um einfach mal,
Eine Entkriminalisierung zu erreichen mit dem damit verbundenen Ziel,
Cannabis rauszunehmen aus diesem typischen Drogenszenen-Spiral-Ding,
dass man quasi zwangsläufig nur, wenn man was zu kiffen haben will,
sich eigentlich in dieselben Strukturen begeben muss, wo halt auch alles andere gehandelt wird.
Und jeder, der da auch mal ansatzweise nur Kontakt hat, weiß, das ist halt auch so.
Und von daher wäre es ja eigentlich besser, man würde einen Umgang finden wie
mit anderen populären Drogen, wie zum Beispiel Alkohol. Mhm.
Fairerweise muss man aber noch sagen, dass Deutschland das auch deshalb oder
hauptsächlich deshalb so kompliziert gemacht hat, weil man eben in internationalen und auch EU,
in internationalen Verträgen und in EU-Gesetzgebung auch so ein bisschen gefangen ist.
Und da, wenn man es eben komplett einfach legalisiert hätte,
dann man da in Konflikt geraten wäre mit der EU und mit verschiedenen Verträgen. Mhm.
So, also das ist halt so ein bisschen der Versuch, diese ganze Regelung zu umschiffen.
Okay, aber das hätte ja nicht unbedingt jetzt bedeuten müssen,
dass man so viele Daten erfassen muss.
Nee, man hätte es auch einfach so machen können wie Kanada zum Beispiel,
die gesagt haben, ist ja zu uns egal. Wäre ja auch eine Option gewesen.
Das wäre jetzt zu einfach.
Das wäre zu einfach. Und vor allem, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Das geht ja nicht, nein.
Genau, also gibt es jetzt diese Cannabis Social Clubs, beziehungsweise kann
es geben, also diese Anbauvereinigung, Cannabis Social Clubs ist so ein bisschen
der Begriff, der sich jetzt so…,
geformt hat.
Ich bin ja Bubas Verein, viel besser eigentlich.
Ich muss ja zugeben, dass ich so als Berufsjugendlicher dann doch sehr spät
erst diesen Begriff entdeckt habe, dass der mittlerweile rumgegangen ist.
Ich auch.
Man lernt ja nie aus.
Ich habe das auch erst jetzt im Rahmen dieser Diskussion habe ich den gelernt.
Genau. Und ja, und was ist dann passiert?
Es ist natürlich das passiert, was passieren musste, um natürlich jetzt so einen
Anbauverein quasi betreiben zu können und um all diese gesetzlichen Anforderungen erfüllen zu können,
braucht man natürlich irgendein System und da bietet es sich natürlich an,
irgendeine fertig gebaute Softwarelösung zu machen.
Und wo kommen die schnell zusammengeworfenen Softwarelösungen her?
Das sind dann irgendwelche Webseiten, die sagen, ja hier, alles gar kein Problem,
klickst du hier, machst du einen Account,
legst du deine Anbauvereinigung an und schon hast du schöne User-Interfaces
und das ist auch alles total sicher und Datenschutz und Privatsphäre und wir
sind ja hier voll die Profis und klick hier.
Und das ist dann immer so der Moment, wo dann unsere Freunde von Zerforschung aufs Feld treten.
So auch in diesem Fall, wir erinnern uns, Zerforschung hat ja nun schon diverse
windige Web-Anbieter irgendwelcher Datenerfassungslösungen auseinandergenommen.
Das fing dann mit diesen Corona-Teststellen an und Lieferdienste und so weiter.
Und das ist halt aus der Perspektive von halbwegs erfahrenen Web-Entwicklern
und so minimal Sicherheitsverstehern.
Also man muss ja jetzt noch nicht mal der totale Experte sein.
Aber wenn man sich irgendwie mit Web-Security ansatzweise mal beschäftigt hat,
dann gibt es halt so zehn Sachen,
ich sag mal so die schnellen Tricks, wo man mal irgendwo rein piekst,
um zu gucken, ob denn irgendwie alles in Ordnung ist.
Und es ist halt dann auch einfach immer wieder dasselbe, diese Lösungen kommen
auf den Markt und dann fangen halt die Leute an, da einfach mal rein zu pieksen,
also ohne jetzt groß da einen Olympia-Rekord aufzustellen im Bereich Security-Analyse,
einfach nur mal so gegentreten, ob der Reifen wackelt und schon fallen die Außenspiegel gleich mit ab.
Und so war es halt auch diesmal.
Opfer war die Lösung CanGuard,
die sich als Verwaltungssoftware für diese Cannabis-Social-Clubs angepriesen
hat und Zerforschung dokumentiert das mal wieder sehr schön auf ihrer Webseite und erläutert,
was halt hier möglich war und es ging natürlich sofort mal wieder los.
Alles, also man konnte, wenn man jetzt so einen Club angelegt hat und da Leute
eingetragen hat mit den entsprechenden Daten,
konnte man sich also einerseits sofort durch die leichte Veränderung der URL
selber schon die eigenen Daten anzeigen,
aber auch die von allen anderen Mitgliedern in diesem Club und das natürlich
nicht nur beschränkt auf den eigenen Club, sondern auch alle anderen Clubs,
die auf demselben Rechner gehostet waren.
Weil du hast ja viel Erfahrung auch mit Datenbanken, dem muss ich das nicht erzählen.
Also das ist sozusagen die absoluten Minima von Datenbanksicherheit,
die hier mit den Füßen getreten werden.
Ja, schlimm.
Man könnte nicht nur die Daten lesen, nein, man könnte sogar auch noch für jeden
User auch noch das Kennwort ändern.
Das ist der Größte, das Allerkrasseste daran, finde ich. irgendwie.
Da dachte ich auch so, Leute, sag mal, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Also viel mehr hätte man auch nicht falsch machen können eigentlich.
Nee, also hier ist wirklich alles dabei. Also klar, man braucht dann noch die
Mail-Adresse, man braucht noch so eine ID von den Usern, aber die kriegt man
ja auch, weil man kann ja einfach mit slash all, kann man sich ja auch alle
User listen lassen und mit allen IDs angezeigt bekommen.
Und die ganze Voraussetzung ist nur, dass man nur irgendwie da einen Account
hat, den man sich ja selber machen kann.
Und dann ging es natürlich dann auch gleich in die nächste Stufe,
nachdem also diese ganzen Fehler gefunden wurden, geht dann halt die Zerforschung,
wie man das eben so macht als verantwortlicher Security-Ingenieur.
Hin und sagt, okay, dann sagen wir doch mal Bescheid, nicht?
Und dann gibt es ja dann entsprechende E-Mail-Adressen, die gelistet werden.
Problem war nur, um den Leuten halt irgendwie Bescheid zu sagen,
dass sie da eine eklatante Sicherheitslücke haben, war dann auf der einen,
also es gab dann sowohl Mail-Adressen in der Datenschutzerklärung als auch im
Impressum, die in der Datenschutzerklärung gelistet waren, die haben schon mal
gar nicht funktioniert, weil die Domain, die dort gelistet wurde,
überhaupt nicht registriert war. Was?
Hast du so. Dingbring.de gab es
halt einfach gar nicht so. Also hättest du kaufen können in dem Moment so.
Und die andere, die so EdKangard.de war, die konnte man zwar anschreiben,
aber es gab halt nach sechs Tagen keine Antwort.
Auch ein zweiter Versuch hat dann irgendwie nichts gebracht.
Und nach dem zweiten Versuch nochmal die Mails zu schicken, konnte die dann
auch schon nicht mehr zugestellt werden.
Was schon mal so ein Hinweis darauf war, dass schon auf die Mails irgendwie
reagiert wurde, bloß eben nicht mit einer Antwort.
Dann waren aber auch noch Telefonnummern gelistet, dort wurden dann mit SMS
darauf hingewiesen, dass sie sich doch vielleicht mal melden sollten.
Und daraufhin ging dann, wir reden jetzt hier vom 4.
April, ging dann das ganze System offline.
Und immerhin haben sie dann am 5. April, ohne sich also irgendwie bei der Zerforschung zurückzumelden,
aber haben sie zumindest ihre Nutzer darüber informiert, dass halt ein Security
Breach vorgelegt hat und dass nach ihrer Erkenntnis natürlich nichts passiert ist.
Nee, ist klar. Sonst hätte es ja Forschung, dass sie es womöglich noch selber
machen müssen, die Leute zu informieren.
Ja, jetzt kann man wirklich in alle Richtungen schlagen. Also auf der einen
Seite finde ich es einfach absurd, dass…,
Ich bin ja wirklich niemand, der jetzt sagen würde, die Welt braucht einen Online-Führerschein.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, bei so manchen Entwicklern würde ich mir das fast mal wünschen,
weil man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, man kriegt hier Autofahren erklärt von Leuten,
die noch nie ein Lenkrad in der Hand gehabt haben.
Ja, wobei, ist es wirklich ein Kompetenzmangel oder ist es einfach nur dieses
übliche schnell schnell hier, das Gesetz tritt in Kraft, wir müssen unsere Lösung fertig kriegen?
Ja gut, aber ich meine auch Lösungen fertig kriegen ist halt Platz 1,
also wenn man damit wirbt und der Betreiber hat ja dann selbst in irgendwelchen
Onlineforen auf Nachfragen und Bedenken nochmal dick rumgepost,
wie sicher ja alles wäre und so.
Also man merkt dann immer, dass dann irgendwelche Marketing-Heinis,
die sich wie welche verhalten, halt einfach mal wild irgendwas behaupten,
weil wahrscheinlich auf einmalige
Nachfrage irgendein Entwickler gesagt hat, ja nee, das passt schon.
Aber man hat halt nicht überlegt, okay, was könnten jetzt unsere Maßgaben sein?
Was sind unsere Möglichkeiten, auch intern das zu testen?
Lassen wir uns mal von außen testen. Organisieren wir mal eine andere Security-Bude,
die Ahnung hat und die hier rumpiksen.
Nein, einfach raus mit dem Kram.
Ja, mit dem Kram. Man muss ja der Erste am Markt sein.
Und das ist doch dem, klar, möglicherweise haben die EntwicklerInnen dann irgendwie
noch was gesagt, ich würde das noch nicht raushauen, aber das ist ja dann im
Zweifel der Geschäftsführung egal.
So ist das. Naja. Gut.
Sabrina, ich sag mal, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut eingetütet.
Vielen Dank für den interessanten Einblick und vielen Dank für deinen Podcast
und nochmal vielen Dank für diesen Bundestagszusammenfasser,
was wirklich ein sehr hilfreiches Tool ist.
Ich hoffe, dass das viele benutzen und ich hoffe, dass sich vielleicht auch
Leute Leute ermuntert fühlen, da noch ein bisschen zu kontributieren,
weil ich glaube, da kann man noch so einiges Nützliches reinbauen,
insbesondere im Hinblick wirklich jetzt auf die Unterstützung des politischen Aktivismus.
Also wenn man sich halt einbringen möchte und frühzeitig und genau und zielgerichtet
und auch sagen wir mal effizient einbringen möchte,
indem man also nicht so viel Zeit erstmal damit verbringt, ja überhaupt erstmal
eine Orientierung zu bekommen, ja keine Ahnung, ich wusste ja gar nicht,
dass jetzt irgendwas hier in Vorbereitung ist.
Ist, kann man jetzt alles auf dem Bundestagszusammenfasser einfach anklicken
und dann weiß man sofort hier,
was steht hier an, Modernisierung des Strafgesetzbuchs ist hier eingeleitet
worden, gibt es ein erstes Eckpunkte-Papier, kann man schon mal draufschauen.
So, und das ist doch schon mal was.
Genau. Ja, das wäre auch gut, wenn das mehr Leute machen würden,
die denen auch an der Demokratie was liegt.
Genau.
So.
Alright.
Nochmal vielen Dank.
Ich danke dir für die Einladung.
Ja, gerne.
Hat mich sehr gefreut, hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Alles klar und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao.